Gedanken schnell mit Computern
kommunizieren das will nur links von
Elon Musk mit seinem Interface für die
Verbindung von Gehirn und Computer
erreichen dazu muss vor allem die
Aktivität von Neuronen im Gehirn
ausgelesen werden das bisher gängige
forschungsgerät das Utah Ray verwendet
dazu Elektroden die wie winzige starre
Nadeln aus einer Platine hervorstehen
einmal implantiert können Sie bei jeder
Bewegung Mikroverletzungen am Gehirn
verursachen die resultierende Narben
isolieren die Elektroden und machen sie
nutzlos nur links Lösung sind Elektroden
die sind dünn und flexibel und bewegen
sich mit dem Gehirn mit dadurch könnte
das Implantat wesentlich sanfter und
langlebiger sein als das Utah
Langzeittests fehlen allerdings noch
wenn du mehr dazu wissen willst dann
folgt uns auf unserem Kanal und schauen
dir unser ganzes Video zu Norwegen an da
reden wir noch ausführlicher über Links
Hauptmission